now speaking of the vaccines if you want
to watch a las vegas raiders game at a
legion stadium this season you're going
to need to show proof that you've been
vaccinated the las vegas freighter is
one of the first nfl teams to roll out
this mandate we have hector mejia live
this morning at allegiant stadium with
reaction from the raider nation hector
good morning
hey there john good morning to you some
people are applauding the decision while
others are pretty angry about this the
raiders are following governor steve
sisselak's recommendation to require
proof of vaccination if you want to go
inside a large event in this case we're
talking about home games so every single
fan who is over the age of 12 will need
the vaccine to go inside a legion
stadium and watch the readers play
they'll get to take off their mask fans
under the age of 12 who are not eligible
for the vaccine yet will need to wear a
mask
all full-time workers are also required
to have the vaccine if you don't have
the shot you can get one on game day but
you must wear the mask inside
we're hearing mixed reaction as more
events across the nation are requiring
proof
i believe it's individual choice and i
would
voice my
opposition to the venue that's a major
stepping stone for las vegas to kind of
set the precedent for the states
when it comes to the players though the
nfl says that through the collective
bargaining agreement they are exempt
from the vaccine mandate but we're told
the raiders have the highest rate of
vaccinated players in the nfl other
teams in las vegas have not made the
same decisions about requiring a vaccine
and for a legion stadium we should point
out this is a decision by the raiders to
require the vaccine allegiance says for
other events all guests still have to
wear a mask regardless of their
vaccination status reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now